DOWN IT GOES.
>> Derek: MAN.
>> Jeff: SEE, YOU
OKEYDOKE.
KLEBER, DOWN IT GOES. 7 OF 9 LA
MINUTES.
TEAMS HAVEFAKE.
>> Chu THE
LEAGUE, REALLY IMPROVED.
SEE IF THEHES JUST BETTER OFFEN.
MICH
THE OTHER END AGAINST LUKA.ND
SLOWS IT DOWN.
LUKA, AROUND THE
WERE FORMER REAL 0 FOR
OFF.
MOSES BROWN RUNS THE FLOOR!
QUARTER, AND
NOW, MOVING SHOOTER.
TIPPED THE BALL AWAY FROM
DeROZAN, CENTERS AWAY AND  SURR
JUST 93 POINTS A THREE RIGHT NO.
LOOKS AT
THE BASKET.
AND A HALF AGO.
BROOKLYN WAS HERE AND THEY BEATO
SAVE THE POSSESSION.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS!
AROUND POWELL.
TO POWELL, WHAT PSES ON LUKA, A
KLEBER HITIT12.
POINT
INJURY.
BIRCH IS OUT WITH A FACIAL
TEXAS!
HT THERE.
READ THE AMERICAN AIRLINES
FIRST TIME THIS YEAR THAT FOR 3
JASON KIDD WANTS TO SEE MORE OF
TONIGHT.
UNTIL NOW! H WAS 33 HERE AT
AMERICAN AIRLINES CEICK FOR
ROBOTICS.
TH
ONE THIS YEAR.
LUKA LOOKING TO ADD TO THE  DON
DRIVE INTO TWO AND FIND POWELL
MURRAY WITH THEINCREDIBLE, FLOO
LaVINE COULDN'T AROUND.
KLEBER IN DEEP.
WILL SCORE IT BASKET.
LEAVES FOR THREE FOR HIM.
BOYON.
YOU PUT YOUR HEAD DOWN, IT'SLUT
>> Jeff: SEE, THEY'RE JUST LIKE